quelques me pose la question pourquoi
est ce que tu est ici c'est justement à
glisser un mot que c'est jésus qui qui
dit de chercher le bien-être de mon
quartier mais mon prochain
vous avez viens d'entendre bradley mort
et c'est le pasteur de cette église du
plateau vous savez on a présenté un
dossier hier plusieurs dizaines de ses
oies et des fidèles de cette église vont
aller prêter main forte à une école
secondaire du plateau pour rouvrir en
quelque sorte une bibliothèque était
condamnée à la fermeture
beaucoup de réactions aujourd'hui à
marie-eve tremblay bonsoir à vous il ya
un lien la faute d'abord le dire direct
avec les compressions parce qu'il ya un
poste de technicienne de bibliothèque
qui a été coupé cet été c'est ça c'est
le cap et fait de l'école secondaire
jeanne mance on parle de postes de
techniciens en documentation qui a été
coupée donc à partir du 1er juillet si
les étudiants ont désiré fréquenter la
bibliothèque à l'école secondaire jeanne
mance devait le faire avec un enseignant
durant les heures de classe donc ce le
fait que les écoles notamment dans ce
cas ci doivent se tourner vers des
bénévoles notamment dans ce cas c'est un
groupe religieux pour pouvoir donner ces
services là c'est une aberration selon
le parti québécois on écoute alexandre
cloutier
mais qu'effectivement c'est une
aberration notre système je peux pas
croire qu'on est rendu si loin dans les
coupures qu'on est obligé de demander à
ce qu'un orthopédagogue soit financée
par un groupe religieux qu'on soit
obligé de demander un gros projet de
s'occuper d'une bibliothèque
ça m'apparaît complètement aberrante au
ministre de l'éducation la clarifier les
règles et à expliquer comment se fait-il
qu'on n'est même pas capable d'offrir
une bibliothèque à l'extérieur des
heures habituelles de classe pour
assurer que nos jeunes puissent pour
avoir accès à ces services
et c'est une école qui misait en plus
faut le dire c'est toute l'ironie sur la
lecture
cette l'école secondaire du plateau les
associations parents qui ont réagi
notamment le comité de parents de la
commission scolaire de montréal la porte
parole dit qu'il y a un besoin il le
reconnaît un besoin criant dans les
écoles donc les bénévoles sont les
bienvenus
si c'est fait à titre personnel et pas
de problème mais c'est au niveau de
l'encadrement ou là elle est certaine
inquiétude et d'autres parents aussi on
l'écoutera intelligent qui pourrait
étudier
enfin la présence auprès du grand
rassemblement religieux pour souhaitable
on l'a vu est la religion de l'école il
ya déjà plusieurs années
le ministre de l'éducation françois bien
n'était pas disponible pour nous
accorder une entrevue aujourd'hui mais
il a quand même réagi au reportage que
nous avons présenté hier nous envoyer
une note en fait son cabinet dit
évidemment il n'ya pas de place au
prosélytisme dans nos écoles les
bénévoles doivent travailler dans le
cadre de la mission de l'école ceci
étant la commission scolaire et l'école
sont responsables de s'en assurer
parce que dans ce cas là et on va
conclure là dessus marie-eve il y à
vraiment plusieurs dizaines de jeunes
qui viennent de cette église là c'est
pas un peu de bénévoles de là un peu de
là un peu de la ja pas dû il n'y a pas
une diversité bénévoles tous les
bénévoles engagés dans cette
bibliothèque là viendrait de cette
église
d'où les questions qu'on pose et je
termine en disant qu'on a bien sûr
demandé j'aurais voulu avoir une
entrevue avec 4 nrl bourdon la président
de la commission scolaire de montréal
paient on ne veut plus manifestement
parler de ce sujet là voilà merci